America's urban decline first began
during the 1950s the process of
suburbanization abetted by prosperity
massive automobile ownership and the
highway system plowed along during this
era as did the deindustrialization of
older cities during the 1920s industries
had left cities for suburbs like
Detroit's River Rouge but after World
War two industry was more likely to
leave the north altogether the
taft-hartley Act of 1948 enabled some
states to pass right-to-work laws which
made unionization far more difficult in
many southern states passed these laws
the work of tom holmes compares
manufacturing growth after 1947 in
counties right on the border of two
states one of which has a right-to-work
law the other of which is pro-union
Holmes found that manufacturing grew far
more in the pro-business states in the
pro-union states and almost all of
America's older colder cities were in
those pro-union states so the 1950s were
a tough time for many of those cities
Boston lost a hundred thousand people
during the decade a 13.7 percentage drop
in its population Detroit's population
shrank by a hundred and eighty thousand
or nine point seven percent Pittsburgh
also lost more than a tenth of its
population but during the 1950's the
population of New York City fell by only
one point four percent 120,000 people
New York was already proving to be
remarkably resilient over the longer
haul of the ten most populous US cities
in 1950 eight of the ten are at least 20
percent less populous today the two
exceptions are Los Angeles and New York
both of which have grown New York's
future looked enormous ly bright in the
early 1960s this was the era in which
glistening glass skyscrapers like Gordon
bunch as lever house and Mies van der
Rohe secret building were built along
Park Avenue the United Nations was
growing in Turtle Bay giving New Yorkers
the feeling that they were citizens of a
capital of the world
Broadway's musicals the works of Rodgers
and Hammerstein still helped define
American culture and Ed Sullivan reached
out from Broadway into tens of millions
of American homes every Sunday at 8:00
the Yankees dominated baseball and in
1961 Roger Maris finally bested Babe
Ruth's homerun record it was the age of
madmen and New York was on top
world 16 years later New York was
essentially bankrupt the city's
population fell from 7.8 million in 1960
to 7.1 million in 1980 by the deadly
burning summer of 1977 it seemed as if
all that bright future was gone what
went wrong how did such bright urban
promise dim so quickly we should start
with the economics the largest
industrial cluster in America in the
1950s was not automobile production in
Detroit
it was garment production in New York as
transportation cost plummeted it became
much cheaper to so ordinary garments in
low-wage southern states than in
Manhattan it was easy to ship them in
later decades it would be even cheaper
to make them in China and Bangladesh in
a few short years during the 1960's the
garment industry which had been a
mainstay of New York City since the
1820s shed hundreds of thousands of jobs
this same story repeated itself
throughout New York's once mighty
manufacturing base New York City's
harbor still thriving when Elliott Kazan
and Marlon Brando made on the waterfront
in 1954 was now made obsolete by New
Jersey's new Elizabeth Marine Terminal
the parent company of Domino Sugar
Refining once the city's most important
industry decided to expand its
facilities in Texas rather than its
landmark Brooklyn Factory in later years
other industries most notably finance
would make up for the lost manufacturing
employment but between 1969 and 1976 New
York lost about 600,000 jobs
social distress accompanied economic
dislocation for centuries New York City
has attracted the world's poor the
world's huddled masses yearning to be
free as Emma Lazarus put it Ellis Island
was the port of entry for millions of
immigrants to America and New York was
also the port of entry for hundreds of
thousands of African Americans fleeing
the Jim Crow South between 1940 and 1970
the number of african-americans in New
York City rose from four hundred sixty
thousand to 1.7 million New York has
benefited enormously from this flow of
talent the genius of the Harlem
Renaissance lit up the city in the world
Queens was blessed with the presence of
Louis Armstrong who was born in New
Orleans for almost 30 years yet the lay
you see a slavery meant that many
african-americans were poor like past
immigrants from Ireland in Eastern
Europe by the 1960s cities weren't
willing to just accept urban poverty
urban reformers like Jerome Cavanaugh
and Michigan and John Lindsay in New
York tried to use city resources to make
poverty less awful a completely laudable
aim but one that's difficult sometimes
to square with the limitations on what
cities can do poverty also came into the
spotlight because of New York City's
rising crime rates in 1957 there were
304 murders by 1961 that number had
increased to 483 in 1967 the year of the
Summer of Love and far less notably my
birth on the island of Manhattan the
number of New York homicides reached 746
by the time I was 5 in 1972 the number
of homicides doubled again to 1691 the
number of annual homicides would remain
over 1,500 for the rest of the decade it
hit 1814 in 1980 almost six times the
figure in 1957 there were safe parts of
the city when I was a kid but they had
shrunk to small amounts of walkable
space and children who grew up in
poverty also grew up looking over their
shoulders fearing robbery or worse Mayor
Lindsay's fun city had become a city of
fear abandoned spaces like the South
Bronx the spoke urban decay the graffiti
that seemed to be everywhere radiated
both urban chaos but also the creativity
that's still surged in the heart of the
city Lindsay may not have been able to
stop the crime wave but he does deserve
credit for helping to keep New York
essentially riot free in the tense hours
after Martin Luther King's death when
New York like much of urban America
seemed on the edge of explosion Lindsay
walked the streets of Harlem he was a
calming caring presence reminding
African American New Yorkers that he was
on their side and they largely believed
him Lindsay had flaws but his commitment
to racial justice could not be
questioned why did crime explode in New
York from 1957 to 1972 crime is
disproportionately an activity of young
men and the baby boom had given America
and New York a lot of young men by the
1960s
but changing demographics can only
explain a small amount maybe a fifth of
the rise in crime found in New York and
elsewhere certainly there was a
breakdown in police effectiveness some
experts have cited a loss and morale
toward our investigations of police
corruption or malfeasance but it's hard
to quantify that theory I think that the
best explanations are largely social the
first line of defense against crime is
not the police force but society as a
whole
parents who restrain their children
successes communities that keep a watch
on the streets the social organization
that once brought some order to New
York's neighborhoods seems to have
weakened dramatically after 1957 the
most famous example of this breakdown
was the 1964 murder of kitty Genovese in
Queens the dying girl's cries for help
were ignored by her neighbors even if
this social hypothesis is correct we
don't know why New York society changed
Jane Jacobs the great urbanist would lay
some blame on public housing projects
which replaced the defensible space of
old tenements with tall towers and open
often empty space in the old
neighborhoods there would be eyes on the
street as people looked out of their
windows from short buildings in the new
towers the streets were divorced from
the apartments and consequently there
are fewer people watching when someone
was mugged my own work with Bruce asset
out documents that street crime is
higher in neighborhoods with taller
buildings even holding income constant
although apartments are actually less
likely to be burglarized than
single-family homes the city responded
to poverty and rising crime by spending
more Lindsay had been elected on a good
government ticket and immediately tried
to rein in spending by getting tough
with public sector unions this Silk
Stocking Republican didn't know the
street brawl that he was going to start
Mike will the tough-as-nails head of New
York's Transit workers went to jail for
leading a 12 day strike in 1966 Lindsay
got an injunction ordering the subways
to start rolling again Lindsay knew how
to work the courts but quill just
ignored the injunction saying that the
judge can drop dead in his black robes I
don't care if I rot in jail I will not
call off the strike
quill won and his workers wages rose by
almost $1 an hour city spending rose
while the city's economy was sputtering
the Lindsay Administration
responded with accounting legerdemain
when Lindsey left office in 1973 the new
mayor a beam former accountant himself
was left to pick up the pieces beam
couldn't do it maybe no one could have
by 1975 New York was on the brink of
bankruptcy beam sought federal help but
President Ford wasn't going to give cash
without some promises that New York
would reform promises that beam couldn't
really make and certainly couldn't keep
when Ford turned him down the daily news
headlines screamed Ford to City drop
dead surely one of the most famous
headlines in history Ford didn't
actually say those words but in those
years it seemed like not just the White
House but history itself was telling New
York City to drop dead New York only
avoided bankruptcy by turning to the
state governor Kerry established the
municipal Assistance corporation which
would keep New York City liquid but
would also take over fiscal control
proud New York had lost the ability to
manage its own finances by the end of
beam's term the city seemed like it was
in total chaos TV cameras during the
1977 World Series caught Bronks
buildings burning the fire department's
ability to respond had been reduced by
budget cuts a summer blackout set off a
crime spree would sharpen contrasted
with a 1966 blackout when the city had
stayed safe
the murderous Son of Sam terrorized the
city in the midst of this Maelstrom Edie
Koch managed to get himself elected
mayor over the discredited beam and the
unforgettable Bella Abzug who once owned
the liberal heart of the city Koch had
also been a liberal lion he became
famous besting the last boss of Tammany
Hall carmine DeSapio but as crime rates
rose Koch morphed into the get tough on
crime candidate 1977 was his year as New
York's voters cast away traditional
ethnic politics and cast away the
liberal hopes of the 1960s the city's
madness needed to be managed and voters
thought that Ed Koch was the man for the
job
you